mai si era tutti ragazzi è vero che
questo video sono con riccardo e sono
felice di questo sono diventato una
piaga sul suo canale chiaia del canale e
magari con quello che è una piaga molto
apprezzato dai ragazzi
noi oggi facciamo una roba un po più
particolare e secondo me migliore
dell'altra volta che è una sfida
veramente straordinaria quindi a turno
una persona dovrà pensare ad un
personaggio veramente eccezione
niente scuse
è così che mi tratti vai al limite del
temibile è una persona a turno pensa ad
un personaggio di vitto pensato ad un
personaggio senza dirlo all'altro quindi
personaggio dei cartoni animati o cose
così poi deve cercare di limarlo
all'altra persona che dovrà cercare di
quindi di capirlo dalle sue da quello
che vede e ridisegnare fare minimo e
disegno qua c'è del talento viene state
tranquilli perché c'è un pelo in bocca
tu disegni e io mimmo al baio perché
almeno facciamo cammino vedere mai
piccolo quindi piccolo è un insetto no
un criceto
no è piccolo e c'è la coda c'è la coda
efficace piccolezza la coda è piccolo
l'ha capito che piccoli e batte le mani
piccola sala coda o il mio disegno
qualcosa di piccolo che ha la coda è sì
bene accetti ok becco cosa cosa sa cosa
devi cosa le orecchie di chi come così
si ok gli occhiali agli occhi gli occhi
e il naso per forza ma c'è un corpo si
scusa
il t rex cos'era leone cane fifone
com'è possibile allora perché mi fai
così perché lo regalino al posto della
gioia da un po ti ricordi quante
d'italia dispone potete dirmi ti poker è
socia la bocca e gli occhi pari a
prescindere se va bene ma io che a volte
non so con quegli occhi di donne che ne
sono le orecchie che hai fatto uguali
gli occhi sono così è vero è però
investito scola quindi mor casi qua e
léon e léon e del care carone va bene
allora adesso titolo dimostrazione di
come invece quello è molto più simile a
quello che faremo detto allora vado con
una se me ne faccio a fare questa cosa
vai cazzato nero una moto kiralaxyl
accende la sfida forte la motosega from
moto a lo scotch e gira così alti si
scontrano delle cose si scontrano cisco
mai una persona è una persona no sono
due cose che mi vedete sono stato
bravissimo bellissimo sono stato
bravissimo
non sono maturo pestavano soltanto due
atlete pensa che è venuto meglio toccano
meglio le tecnologie era che io che sono
dei problemi che a peluso è perché c'è
noi non è sì che tale perché le basi per
dare la vittima no grazie cosa nella
scatola non era una motosega e bello
dobbiamo fare 5 a testa gli esami gesti
blade c'e la vedi tu sì sì sì e chi sa
che non ce l'avevamo ce l'avevate questo
è bellissimo
vai se lo dici tu
corre cosa che cosa si corrono e holly e
benji no
mille ciro no è un calciatore si con le
gambe rosa o liga è la posizione che
calzano tipo così ei capelli così la
maglietta la maglietta 67 scusa terreno
dei giochi che cos'era era holly e benji
però cristiano ronaldo non è in serie
praticamente nostre zitto orecchie ha
ancora in mezzo un triangolo un
triangolo delle bermuda a delle permuta
new york aveva aspetta
bellissimo lo faccio benissimo guarda
qua no faccio un occhio nero aveva ben
hanno picchiato dai non rompere sono
molto bravo ai trenta secondi ok lindo
minuto la capacità di dominare non è la
capacità e le subito sono io che ho la
capacità di partendo da minare subito
spesso dai capelli i capelli ci stanno
era basta questo qua ci sta poi queste
cose solo fare questo
poi il resto sera hanno fatto 38 del
millennio è sicura 13 maggio del
millennium del altri anche non avrei mai
cosa è inconfondibile vero per appare
domande fare domande è un poveraccio fai
solo domande sei quello che sto dicendo
è quello che stai dicendo
però non mi non è quindi come sempre va
bene non lo so ce la farei mai
togliamo in standby ciccione ciccione
concezione poi è ma nudo sì questo video
è finito bene dai lei tutto sotto ma ce
la faccia anche facendo inventa la palla
veloce bravo madonna così credibile e la
telecamera di avere una telecamere mano
ok c 45 secondi beh basta è perfetto va
benissimo indovinavano tu quando mi fa
paura senza la faccia perché fatto una
se norme sembra tipo di gioco di parole
però senza la faccia era lui che ha
fatto alla facciata no va bene benissimo
pulci solo una videocamera generosissimo
guarda fantastico e molto bello perché
marco è una grandissima mullah ma io
sono convinto che con questo quadra
domani ci ha già lavorando a verissimo
ha la fortuna di 5 minuti co so già che
queste 3 2 1 la persona con problemi a
parte quello che ho capito mi hai capito
perché io faccio i gesti iconici sì che
siano ronaldo vado quante cavolate non
lo magnifica
allora questo questo qua è la persona o
il io dovrei avere un volto più spazio
di cortei pro die die ai 20 secondi e
questo è il suo incubo peggiore è venuto
meglio di quello che avevo fatto l'altra
volta basta basta fermo che cos'era
ashcan esatto però sembra più gli
squilli esatto il naso esperto che
square tale abbiamo fatto in colpo di
stallo idea noi una protagonista brava
bene dai ben by sea mister muscolo cosa
air culés no e muscoloso e impettito è
muscoloso impedito sì sì sì cosa cosa
rivestito un mantello o un martello e
superman no si aspetta al mantello così
capitan america si ha uno scudo allora
ai 10 secondi
cavolo il video moniaci così va bene
bellissimo questo è capita merluzzo
com'era e com'è fatto cosa per quanto
riguarda era rosso rosso blu e bianchi e
noi già ok dopo aveva delle stelle
comunque no spesso è davvero difficile
come difficile già io abito vigile 3 2 1
ma perchè vi sono tutti questi due
personaggi le spice girl e dota di spies
le canta zac efron è uguale
io per me quella che può essere così fa
bene ai 20 secondi da un sacco 10
secondi cos'è che non saprei come
disegnarla allora questa guerra davvero
difficile vero che spaventa passeri
samara che è che ho fatto un po di
capelli ho provato a ricordarvi qualcosa
ma doveva essere sailor moon mafia vi
sia piaciuto oggi saputo disegnare
grazie anche io quando capita sono
contento anch'io ho messo il mio massimo
questo per me io potrei a prenderlo ma
garda pian piano secondo me forse fare
video migliorerai noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video un bacino vi siete dal
canale anche quello di riccardo trovati
descrizione e noi da ragazzi
[Musica]